target has repeatedly donated to a group
that secretly transes the kids this is
the gay lesbian straight education
Network known as GL sen it's an entity
which helps teachers Place lgbtq Books
in school libraries and hides their
students so-called gender transitions
from parents this goes a lot deeper than
anybody thought and so if we're going to
replace the current Elite we can't
accept the limited hangout that these
corporations and political entities are
giving us where they say okay here's
some random middle manager VP of
marketing yeah okay she's fired or she's
placed on administrative leave but we're
going to leave the rest of the
executives in charge no we have to
replace the current Elite Personnel is
policy